myanmar's senior general
minong lai arriving in jakarta ahead of
saturday's summit
his invitation has caused uproar in
myanmar granting legitimacy to the coup
say protesters that anger was reflected
by demonstrators outside the asean
secretariat compound
the ferocity of the military crackdown
and the rising death toll
has drawn condemnation around the world
but as the southeast asian leaders
gathered it was clearly going to be a
testing day
splits have emerged in the group
malaysia indonesia and singapore
have been openly critical others most
significantly thailand
have been relatively quiet since the
coup
but as they went into closed session it
was clearly not going to be an easy ride
for myanmar's senior general
in that meeting i said several things
one the development of the situation in
myanmar is unacceptable
and should not continue violence must be
stopped
democracy stability and peace in myanmar
must be returned immediately
what has emerged from the summit is a
five-point plan
calling for an end to the violence and
the release of
all political prisoners
he must restrain himself and his forces
so that tension could be relieved
a request for a second commitment an
inclusive dialogue process must begin
immediately
political prisoners must be released and
an asean special envoy
needs to be formed namely the secretary
general of asean and the chair of asean
to encourage dialogue
with all parties in myanmar but will the
military comply
asean has tried to reign in myanmar's
military before
in the 90s and early 2000s to little
avail on the streets of darwin
protesters were back out once again as
they were in many of myanmar's cities
first in convoys of motorbikes and then
on foot
they will also be hard to placate having
shed so much blood
and will they accept returning to a
system where their democracy
is overseen by the military tony chang
al jazeera